♪ ♪
>> $6 BILLION NYPD SOCIAL
INVESTMENT TERRY STATE OF OUR --
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES.
IN AOC'S CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT,
VIOLENT CRIMES ARE UP 57%
COMPARED TO JUST TWO YEARS AGO.
>> JUDGE, I THOUGHT THAT CRIME
SHOULD PAY.
FEELS THAT LIBERAL PROSECUTORS
FEEL THAT IT DOESN'T PAY.
>> I THINK WITH THE PROSECUTORS
ARE DOING TODAY, ESPECIALLY THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFTISTS, THEY ARE
MAKING CRIME PAY FOR THE
CRIMINAL.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN GO INTO
STORES AND STEEL UP TO
AND TAKE $1,000 IN PRODUCTS
COME UP TO, AND JUST KEEP
GETTING AWAY WITH IT.
THE SADDEST PART IS WE TAKE
SOMEONE LIKE
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ AND SAY
THAT SHE SHOULD BE THE VOICE OF
REASON IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
CRIME.
SHE'S KNOW NOTHING ABOUT CRIME
OR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS A WOMAN THAT HAS NO
BACKGROUND IN THIS, AND FOR SOME
REASON GOT ALL THE ATTENTION,
AND NOW WE HAVE A WOMAN
COMPLAINING WHEN WE HAVE A 57%
INCREASE IN CRIME IN
NEW YORK CITY.
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THE NYPD IN
DROVES.
THEY AREN'T EVEN WAITING FOR
THEIR PENSION.
THEY JUST WANT TO GET OUT.
POLICE ARE DEMORALIZED,
DEHUMANIZED.
OH, WHAT WE HAVE IN OUR COUNTRY
IS A CONTINUED FIGHT, BUT WITH
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE BECOMING
VICTIMS, THERE IS GOING TO A
MOVEMENT VERY SOON WHERE PEOPLE
WILL SAY "I'VE HAD ENOUGH."
RON DeSANTIS, GOOD FOR HIM.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE A PROSECUTOR.
YOU PROSECUTE CRIME, PROTECT THE
VICTIMS.
THESE PEOPLE KNOW NOTHING OF IT.
>> NOT ONLY ARE MAJOR FELONIES
UP, BUT HOMICIDE IS UP 44%.
THE DEFUND THE POLICE MOVEMENT
HAS DECIMATED COMMUNITIES, MANY
OF WHICH ARE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS WILL PAY
A PRICE FOR THIS NOVEMBER?
>> WE COULD.
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO CONTINUE
ON THIS ISSUE.
POLICE OFFICERS NEED TO BE
FUNDED.
REFORM OF OBEY ALL LAWS NEEDS TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
THE INSTINCT OF THOSE LAW REFORM
WAS -- NONVIOLENT CRIMINALS
SPENDING MORE TIME IN JAIL THAN
THEY WOULD IF THEY WERE
CONVICTED OF THE CRIME.
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS THE
EXACT OPPOSITE.
MIGHT HAVE SEEN THIS IN OUR
LOCAL NEWSPAPER.
ONE OF OUR TOP POLICE OFFICIALS,
A GUY NAMED JON MILLER, HE SAID
THAT THE BAIL REFORM LAWS WOULD
SET NEW YORK CITY BACK A DECADE,
AND THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE.
YOU SEE THESE GUYS, INCLUDING
ONE TO YOUR LEFT HE'S ONE OF THE
GREAT ADVOCATES TO ADDRESS THIS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE ON THE
STREETS.
NOT ONLY IN NEW YORK --
BUT A PREPONDERANCE OF OUR
CHALLENGES IN THE EAST CORE
DOOR.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ALIKE.
THERE ARE NO AMOUNT OF --
BUILDING BACK BETTER THAT WILL
MAKE THIS WORK RIGHT.
THE GOOD TO ME, IT SEEMS THAT
THE GIST OF DUMB I COULD GIVE
DEMOCRATS A PASS.
THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO GET A
COMPLETE PASS FOR MOST OF THE
MEDIA ON CRIME.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE MEDIA
IS BIASED?
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU HAVE TO CUT AOC A BIT OF
SLACK, BECAUSE SHE'S PLANNING A
WEDDING.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE HAS NOT SPOKEN TO THE MAYOR
OF NEW YORK CITY IN OVER A YEAR.
WHY NOT?
THEY ARE BOTH DEMOCRATS.
WORK TOGETHER FOR THE GOOD OF
THE CITY, BUT SHE IS PETTY, SO
SHE WON'T DO THAT.
SHE DOES NOT WORK ACROSS THE
AISLE, DOESN'T WORK ON HER OWN
SIDE OF THE AISLE.
SHE HAS NOT HAD A SINGLE
ELECTRIC CAR CHARGING STATION IN
HER DISTRICT, BUT THAT'S HER
MAIN ISSUE.
SHE TALKS MORE ABOUT CRIME AND
ISRAEL THAN HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
I LOOKED AT HER WEBSITE, OR
PRESS RELEASES.
SHE HAS NOT PUT OUT A RELEASE IN
A YEAR ABOUT CRIME IN NEW YORK.
THE ONLY THING SHE SAID ABOUT
CRIME --
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT SHE SAID
WHEN MAYOR ADAMS SAID SHE WANTS
TO HIRE MORE POLICE, SHE SAID
"VIOLENCE, I DON'T NEED PEOPLE
COMMITTING IT.
I ALSO MEAN THE SYSTEM AND POWER
COMMITTING IT AGAINST THE
PEOPLE."
IF YOU ARE A CONVICTED FELON OR
SOMEONE OUT THERE NOT CONVICTED
YET, YOU ARE A VICTIM OF
VIOLENCE BY THE RACIST AND
CAPITALIST SYSTEM OF AMERICA.
THAT'S HOW SHE SEES THINGS,
--
EVERYONE IS A VICTIM OF THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM.
>> IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE ON THE
ISSUES -- PROSECUTORS NOT
PROSECUTING.
SO MANY BIG CITIES, ESPECIALLY
CALIFORNIA, YOUR HOME STATE,
THEY HAVE LOST THEIR MINDS.
>> I WILL DEFINITELY BRING IT UP
TO HER AT THE WEDDING.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GREAT ABOUT AOC?
SHE'S WRONG ON EVERYTHING, BUT
ENFORCES EVERYBODY TO DO THEIR
HOMEWORK.
SHE COMES OUT, SAYS SOMETHING
WRONG, AND THEN WE HAVE TO DO
THE RESEARCH.
SHE WILL SAY THAT CRIME ISN'T
HAPPENING --
THE STATISTIC OF 57% HAS GONE UP
SINCE SHE HAS BEEN IN POWER.
THAT CAME FROM A "NEW YORK POST"
ARTICLE.
THIS IS THE RESEARCH, THE CRIME
STATS THAT WE END UP HAVING TO
DO.
IT JUST MAKES HER LOOK SO BAD.
CONSTITUENTS -- MORE LIKELY TO
BE MUGGED, ASSAULTED, SHOT AT
SINCE SHE WAS ELECTED.
SO CLOSE TO THE ACTION.
I'M SORRY, SHE WASN'T.
IN THE BRONX, SHE'S IN HER TESLA
WITH HER FRENCHY AND DORKY
FIANCE.
>> NOW, YOU ARE DEFINITELY NOT
INVITED.
[L